alors philippe en dise et que c'est
petit portrait à la façon de la bruyère
des petites maximes qui deviendront
peut-être des citations
alors je vous faire une interview faire
valoir j'allais voir comme je suis
gentil respectueux avec vous on va
parler de vos citations et je vous ai
préparé des fiches avec vos citations
comme ça vous n'aurez même pas besoin de
vous en servir et vous aller briller
intensément quand monastique tenue et
puis vous avez les questions value
question c'est moi qui les posent et les
réponses c'est vous qui les fait voilà
c'est pas gentil ça pour vous c'est quoi
un artiste bah c'est quelqu'un qui a
réussi à transformer des défauts
caractériel en qualité professionnelle
même carlos
oui etes-vous modeste oui mais vous le
savez la modestie cesse à l'instant où
on commence à en parler
pourquoi avez vous essayé de tricher
avec les impôts philippe jeu
les impôts ont été inventés pour tout le
monde n'est pas envie de réussir mais
tant que nouvelle fois là on appelle
mauvaise foi les convictions d'autrui
qu'on ne partage pas vous pensez quoi
des hommes bah je m'étonne toujours que
des êtres également menacé par la mort
se fasse la vie aussi difficile alors
qu'il doit y avoir une solidarité de
condamner êtes vous un honnête homme
philippe bouvard l'honnêteté la seule
méthode qui permette d'escroquer
plusieurs fois la même personne
comment expliquez vous qu'on voit plus à
la télé c'est votre image on vous savez
nous vivons dans un monde où l'échec des
autres devient plus importante notre
propre réussite
vous avez du talent selon vous non non
mais bon le talent font si c'est à dire
les mêmes bêtises que les autres mais
plus élégamment et j'ajouterais parce
que c'est un des principes fondamentaux
de la radio plus vite que les autres
avez vous peur de vieillir philippe
bouvard non je suis curieux de voir ce
que ça donne quoi que
le matin je suis pas toujours réjoui de
ce que je jouais dans le miroir de ma
salle de bains mais je pense que les
hommes sont comme les mains lorsqu'ils
deviennent meilleurs en vieillissant
c'est qu'ils sont d'une certaine qualité
vous avez du caractère non dans notre
société on dit que quelqu'un du
caractère quand il accorde plus
d'importance à ses propres opinions
cause à vis d'autrui nous et qu 50 ans
avec la même femme c'est quoi votre
secret elle a suivi le premier
commandement de la femme adultère
catholique tu aimeras ton prochain comme
le précédent
merci philippe bouvard avait été bien
aimable nom de rien à leur envier
la politesse des gens qui n'ont pas ils
font n'est pas du tout pendant les
heures de boulot
oui
idji mauvaise nouvelle pour vous
maintenant je vais être obligé de dire
au revoir à nos amis suis un peu triste
c'est tout à fait abbandonata subito et
voilà vous vous attachez de 3,8 oui
c'est mon surtout quand elles sont cinq